at the psychotherapy development center
with with whom we hope you all come and
collaborate on some of this work we've
one of the treatments that we've been
developing is cognitive behavioral
therapy if you don't know what cognitive
behavioral therapy is Brett talked about
a little bit I mean it's just sort of
the apple pie motherhood of therapy it
works for just about everything any kind
of behavioral disorder at all it's safe
it's very broadly effective it works for
yes the skills training for depression
anxiety safe sex you name it and it's
durable while not necessarily more
effective than any other empirically
validated treatment we have at this
point it certainly is durable and we've
shown sleeper effects where people
continue to improve even after they
leave treatment but what I had was a
horrible dissemination problem great
night of publishes the manual it's they
send it to every clinician in the
country and nobody uses it that's the
thing cbt although that's no place to go
cbt oh those sort of wonderful is kind
of hard to learn clinicians have
practically no time at this point to do
it if you're not great at it it can seem
like it's really repetitive and what
generally happens now in drug abuse
treatment programs is that clinicians
can have case loads of up to 90 people
in a week there's no way you can deliver
CBT effectively under under those
conditions and so we have very weak
delivery and this is this will be sort
of an echo of what you've heard all
through the day but why I moved to
computer facilitated delivery what were
things like we we know effective
implementation of CBT is very very rare
I've taken something like four or five
hundred tapes of treatment as usual from
up from a CTN study and looked at even
though the people were saying they were
doing CBT the actual number of times CBT
was recognizable in those tapes was
about 20 times it's just not happening
20 out of 400 times skills training was
even mentioned we also know that only a
small fraction
people with addiction related treatment
as problems actually access treatment
we've talked about rural and underserved
populations and the way I think about
these treatments so far is not
necessarily a standalone interventions
we haven't gotten that far yet but
certainly as clinician extenders the
clinician can serve as a case manager or
general contractor oh you've got
substance use here's beating the blues
oh you know you owe you do so they can
sort of direct people to the correct
computer assisted therapy they're
broadly accessible and available all the
time and I'm really beginning to think
that there are some things computers can
do better than some clinicians one of
which is actually show examples show
people really implementing them you know
in a wide variety of situations and
we'll get back to that in a second there
you know unlike a therapy I'm not like a
therapist the computer doesn't really
get bored and so you can certainly
individualize you can you know the
patient can do whatever he wants with
them and I'm a psychotherapy researcher
and you probably can't see the purple
but one thing this is is yes it gets
therapies out there the other thing it
does is that for the first time ever we
can really control our therapies and so
instead of just throwing CBT or these
big packages to people as a mishmash
what these what computer assisted
therapies let us do is it's sort of
direct specifically what modules of what
components go to what people and we
could begin to understand what's really
important what's in what's an active
ingredient of the treatment and what's
not so important and you have
standardization of treatment which we
certainly don't have in substance use
treatment um so I got a knight a merit
award for in order to develop what we
call CBT for cbt we took it from we took
the content from our nida CBT manual
which had been validated many times so
it has seven modules they take about an
hour each and what we wanted to do was
think about well what we wanted to do
was was was not put up
a web-based system with just a lot of
text to read there's an awful lot of
systems like that and our thinking was
there's no way a cocaine user is going
to sit through that just so we had to
make it engaging fun something people
really wanted to do so it you know so I
sort of did it you know that the I
basically ripped it off from Clifford
the Big Red Dog which time which taught
my daughter to read so we make lots of
multimedia use presentation of skills
through movies we hired actual actors
and and and directors to shoot these
little movies of real people in
difficult high-risk situations they
would not use coping skills screw up in
use drugs then we use a variety of
different multimedia to teach them the
teach the skills and then we see the
movie again but this time it has a
different ending because you see the
person use the skill and so it's really
fun and we did lots of quizzes and
interactive exercises and lots and lots
and lots of homework so this is just an
example of our safe sex module so
there's this couple at this party and
she drinks and succumbs to his advances
it's terrible we teach the skill and
then she responds assertively she
doesn't drink so you see her actually
use all the skills and so we did a this
is our first trial it was done as a
pilot so you have to keep that in mind
what we did was just add CBT for cbt to
treatment as usual at a community drug
abuse center in Bridgeport Connecticut
patients cook who were assigned to that
condition could come to the clinic and
use the CBT for CT CBT program up to
twice a week in the little therapists
office it was all private and we did a
six-month follow-up in and as you've
been hearing to in these web based
studies it's really nice because you
really can kind of take all comers you
don't have to restrict your population
too much and cbt for cbt is very broad
as to what type of drug use alcohol
pretty much everybody can use it so
we've got a nice I think representative
population this was not an easy
population so only about seventy percent
we're working a lot had that little
probation push into treatment and most
people were using a lot of whatever
seventy-nine percent where users of more
than one drug plus alcohol and for this
little eight-week thing so twice a week
on average people finish maybe seven
sessions which was okay we got a
distally significant effect on urine
specimens which is hard to do in an in a
drug study so this looked very very good
for its first outing that also
translated to good outcomes in terms of
longest consecutive period of abstinence
which is important for drug abuse
research because that's usually a really
strong indicator of how people are going
to do in the long term and people love
this the I think it's it's fun it's
interesting the clinicians were sneaking
upstairs to look at the program and
they'd say oh now I get what CBT is and
laughs great you know you said you've
been knowing it so we've actually
developed a working alliance inventory
for technology because it does appear
that people really do get connected to
these kinds of things that I think Brett
referred to that they or the characters
or whatever so we're sort of chasing
that down and I was a little worried
that the clinicians would be alienated
by this oh my god you're going to take
pic over and not let me be a clinician
anymore they really saw it as an
extender of their work as well and we're
quite positive about it just very
quickly other things that we found out I
think you mentioned before technology is
just a way of delivering something and
it matters if that something is good or
if it stinks and so we wanted to see
well are we really delivering something
that looks like CVT so does it teach the
coping skills that we're targeting does
that make any difference at all and do
we see the sleeper effect and by god yes
so we have this little task where we get
people to articulate the the skills that
they've learned and you know generally
they start out saying in a high-risk
situation oh I just go out and use
at the end of treatment they tend to be
able to say something like oh I wouldn't
go to the party or they could they can
articulate a coping skill so that's not
necessarily proof that they've got the
behavior but they can talk to talk now
the fun thing about CBT for cbt is even
though we stopped access to the program
at the end of the eight weeks we got a
sleeper effect for skills acquisitions
their skills got better six months into
it which was really interesting and I
think that I hope that reflects that
what we try to do is teach the CV skills
is very generalizable so coping with
craving is something you do to kind of
get over a period of craving but it's
also a great metaphor for learning
effect tolerance in response inhibition
and we teach it that way here's the
specific thing but here's how it's tied
to sort of general effective behavior
and we got the sleep of sleeper effect
on drug use too so here's this little
program over eight weeks and we're
seeing effects on substance use and
urines six months later so that was
really pretty good although it's sort of
a no-brainer to say these things are
cost-effective you can release get a
paper out of it so so we work with Todd
Olmstead from le pH and then did a
little cost-effectiveness thing and and
and and this is this is in comparison to
some of our other evidence-based
treatment for addictions but you know
once the thing is built it's sort of a
no-brainer it's cheaper and more
effective than treatment as usual when
you bring it up to scale so we're doing
a lot now so that we we just finished a
trial we added the HIV module that
covers both needle use and and safe sex
behavior we've done that at the eff
foundation we've got 100 randomized now
we've got fMRI in genetics on it we're
looking at things like do they actually
understand the CBT concepts we've also
got a complicated factorial trial in
methadone population in Bridgeport and
what we're doing there is seeing if
it's cognitive behavioral therapy is
very cognitively demanding on patients
and since most of our patients come in
with memory and attention problems we're
using gland to me which is used in mild
dementia to see if so we can sort of amp
up their brains a little bit and deliver
cbt more effectively or at least get
them to remember it we were in the
middle of a planning stages of a ve a CS
a cooperative studies where we'll be
looking at hopefully treatment as usual
treatment as usual plus cbt or CBT alone
we're evaluating it in comparison to
individual treatment and we're waiting
to hear about a couple things a Spanish
version is a no brainer I I am so tired
of 25 years in this work work and never
being able to get people who only speak
Spanish into our trials because they
can't manage all these kinds of things
this just seems like a great thing to do
so now I want to get to the caveats
because it seems like everybody's
talking about that so computer assisted
therapy is great great great great great
they're available you can't master
multiple you bp's they're cheap but the
question is also sort of why why we when
we have these what do we do with them
I've never in my 25 years of work had
anything anybody ever wanted to buy you
know but all of a sudden I published
this paper everybody wants to buy cbt
for cbt it's one trial with 70 patients
in one outpatient setting how do we know
it actually works and so one of the
things that we get to with this is once
we develop these things how do we really
know that they work and there's huge
temptation to disseminate quickly and I
just wanted to be a little careful about
about how we do that so should we just
assume that all these things are safe
and effective I don't know that should
we assume that broad dissemination and
even if it does a little bit of good
that's better than nothing I don't know
there's a lot of adverse events that
could be associated with
broad dissemination of these things
before we're ready people could drop out
of treatment they could they could
interpret something that the computer
does in an inappropriate way they could
detox themselves too fast they could you
know go through an exposure protocol too
fast nobody is reporting on adverse
events so far and confidentiality is a
huge thing with illegal drug users at
least there is no computer system that
can't be hacked so when we went to the
web for this what we had to do very
carefully we set up the program we're
under no circumstances could we track IP
addresses or have any sort of open boxes
where the patients could put in
information that could be damaging so
we'd be really really careful so I
probably not have any time to do this
but with Brian Killick we just published
and it's on the web a methodological
analysis the computer assisted therapies
and what we tried to do so it's it's
it's it came out like last week what we
did was just survey the literature on
treatment of adults with xs-1 disorders
via computer assisted therapy and this
was not and a typical meta-analysis all
we wanted to do is just see how good is
the data on which all this is based oh
yeah okay because you know there's a lot
of things going on with internet
research that that make it complicated
how do you know you're actually dealing
with patient or their dog and just very
briefly as we've developed a coding
system for evaluating the quality of the
research and this is a quick overview
they do fine with randomization but as
was mentioned before there's huge
follow-up and only fifteen percent of
the studies bother to have a follow-up
that gets at least eighty percent of the
intention-to-treat sample so we're just
looking at outcomes for the people who
get the therapy and like it there's also
huge problems with assessment in terms
of self-report only oh do you feel
better yet I feel better great you know
so yeah I'm it's important to get
biological or some sort of independent
evaluation of what's going on huge
problems with missing data and a lot of
the states it was sort of interesting
the UK National Health Service
adopted this program called beating the
blues for depression on the basis of I
think five studies for depression in
which none of the participants met
criteria for actual access one
depression they were just sort of bummed
out yeah I mean it's so people get so
excited they kind of get ahead of the
data here there's very little data on
adherence and internal validity as well
as the credibility of the control
condition so what we found in so there's
about 75 studies that are out there now
none of them met current methyl
standards that would be required for
either a real behavioral trial or a
pharmacologic trial no studies reporting
on adverse events we have to get ahead
of that I went through some of the
common problems a minute ago the most
common design designed for these things
is here's my insomnia treatment here's
my weightless control just get self
report on patients that doesn't really
show anything so we have to we have to
really be careful so we're the the
methodology I think that's the cat catch
up to our excitement and to some degree
let the buyer beware when it come to
some of these things